en fait j'ai transformé ma passion en
quelque chose que je peux monétiser pour
pouvoir vivre et faire que ça et c'est
ça la vraie richesse
en tout cas moi c'est ce que mes parents
ont toujours souhaité me chercher parce
que je fasse des grandes études que je
sois et m'ont juste dit travaille bien à
l'école et prend pas de drogue et fait
en sorte que ce que tu aimes c'est ce
que tu feras tout comme ça ta part de
son travail
salut brut des revenus à mika ça venait
à l'hôtel mahfouf
[Musique]
sur youtube
j'ai commencé il ya quatre ans je crois
maintenant et mes vidéos étaient en
anglais au début et j'avais un boulot
également tout ça qui était un blog de
mode et s'était exclusivement en anglais
et c'est écrit en anglais parce que
j'avais peur que les gens de ma classe
dans l'école à tous manque de moi tout
simplement
et j'ai pris plus de temps à réfléchir
en disant j'ai envie de faire des vidéos
plutôt qu'à faire des vidéos salut les
gars vous avez bien dans cette même
vidéo
j'ai du mal à m'en rends compte de mon
influence quoi que ce soit parce que bah
je sais pas moi je suis chez moi tu vois
je ne vois pas que quand c'est un
mélange entre un million de gens ça fait
si longtemps qu'on sait pas vu à temps
vous fais la bise je m'en rends compte
quand les gens me le dise ou quand une
marque média pure et le produit les
soldats août ou quand les pétitions plus
de signature d'un coup ou quand on
envoie des messages pour me dire merci
pour le coup de pouce c'est vraiment ça
nous a beaucoup aidés donc ouais tout ça
c'est là où je mens rencontre mais sinon
je vois les vues et c'est tellement
beaucoup de chiffres que c'est chaud
non mais je pense que la chose que j'ai
eu c'est que j'ai commencé assez tard tu
vois genre c j'ai commencé mes études
j'avais 18 ans donc j'avais déjà galéré
pour avoir de la tueuse j'avais un petit
boulot j'avais déjà le rythme de vie de
l'école parce que l'école cette force
quand même un sort une certaine
discipline et donc je suis pas arrivé
tout de suite à 2 ans voit même pas
tomber dessus c'est je travaillais pour
l'avoir donc j'ai eu tous les trucs
crescendo tout le monde me voyait
arriver du jour au lendemain mais ça
fait vraiment 4 en moins voilées
chiffres qui font ça c'est crescendo
alors là pas un mot clic dans ma
carrière
un pic j'ai lu après j'ai une famille à
ma down 2 millions d'abonnés sur
instagram ou 5n en affaires c'est mon
père c'est pareil ils m'ont sifflé c'est
le cadet de ses soucis donc quand à base
solide vraiment est là pour toi et parce
que tu représentes tout ce que tu peux
apporter
non sous celle du hamas
[Musique]
j'ai mal je te confirme sa housse ne pas
vouloir banaliser la santé mentale parce
qu'en fait c'est très difficile de
s'occuper des autres et de vivre encore
en société si toi tu vas pas bien plus
que je me suis réveillé malheureusement
avec une crise angoisses et je n'ai pas
aimé l'ambiance mais le concept donc je
recommande pas n'achetez pas l'écrire on
voit ce que je t'ai initiait se stresser
à la base pas toujours très positive
donc ça ça a évolué mais après le lent
que cet essai venu surtout moins que la
pression puisque du coup il ya des gens
qui regardent que je fais mais en fait
tu vois je fais que les réseaux sûre en
tout cas ce dôme boucau tête tu vois ça
devienne un endroit complexant c'est
toujours rassurant de savoir qu'il ya
quelqu'un peu importe où est ce qu'il
est qui vit la même chose que toi
je faisais mes blogs bah tu voyais mais
je voulais tout paris sait jamais ça
j'allais laisser naturel et même là j'ai
encore plein de victimes distincts c'est
trop cool de voir en interview avec tes
cheveux bouclés parce que après je ne
sais pas non encore aujourd'hui j'en
sois vla l'appétence mon corps surnom
sur la façon dont je m'habille sur mon
style sur plein de trucs on a tous des
complexes que ce soit une bosse sur le
nez les cheveux bouclés des anges
trollage des robin des bois un double
menton petit pois de primes que je
connais vous inquiétez pas les
réflexions vraiment qui me passe au
c'est la façon sur le corps quoi c'est
pas comme si je pouvais faire quelque
chose et surtout qu'en fait j'ai compris
que je l' ai vu la petite poitrine tu
vois genre on en veut on veut me dit que
j'ai une petite poitrine lors d'un show
courant puisque elle à moi donc je la
vois tu vas tous les matins donc je le
sais et au delà tasser tu sais très bien
ce qu'on dirait si j'avais de nous des
gros seins tout c'est une femme qui
vulgaire tu peux plus mettre de
décolletés trop c'est trop vulgaire mais
quand tu as des petits seins on dit que
j'ai des pecs et que je devrais pamela
décolleté c'est un peu la honte
et quant à une poitrine de taille assez
normal dans ce titre été matée basique
mais si tu as un refait battez pas
naturel donc tu as toujours en tout cas
à dire et puis à part ton moment tu te
rends compte de ça ça va plus que j'ose
également été compliqué aujourd'hui a
dit mais c'est complexe
dans une société qui est régner par des
neufs robben d alexia neil et kim
kardashian et desquels ils génèrent qui
a mon âge et qui le genre 45 paye de
plus de poitrine comme moi mais les gars
afin de volant trop envie non moule on
est trop jeune et mon grand objectif
pour 2021
c'est de réussir à mieux structurer tout
ce que je fais j'aimerais rester à
trouver une meilleure balance à mieux
gérer mon temps à déléguer leur
peut-être plus de trucs sur tout ce qui
va être la comptabilité
et certains points certains aspects de
production et tout est comme ça je
prévois mieux mes amis et même encore
pas loin de ma famille et tout puisqu'à
la fin de la journée c'est ça le vrai
bonheur
c'est pas travail